once again Vladimir Putin has threatened
to use nuclear weapons in the course of
his war against Ukraine in his TV
address to the nation just recently
announcing a level of mobilization he
even said this is not a bluff now it's
not the first time that Putin has made
nuclear threats during the course of
this crisis so what does this threat
mean how dangerous is this moment well
to find out I spoke to one of the
world's leading experts on nuclear
conflict James Acton of the Carnegie
endowment Think Tank based in Washington
DC I started by asking him to spell out
just what it is that Vladimir Putin has
threatened now
Putin threatened to use nuclear weapons
in a set of circumstances including
threats to the territorial Integrity of
Russia the livelihood and well-being of
the Russian people
um but for me this was actually it was a
clear nuclear threat and as such it was
dangerous and Reckless
um and one that I take seriously
um but it was also I think a vague
nuclear threat and not everybody agrees
with this analysis
um but you know my view is we can't read
into this this precise and specific
circumstances in which Putin would use
nuclear weapons I very much felt that he
has defined those precisely in his own
mind the way that I interpret this
threat is if things go badly in
unspecified ways then Putin is reserving
the right to use nuclear weapons so how
would you draw a distinction between
what he said in this address and what he
said at the beginning of the war so just
announcing the war he made nuclear
threats also just a few days after the
beginning of the war he also uh declared
that he was putting nuclear forces on a
certain level of alert which was rather
unclear how would you draw a distinction
between what he said now and what he
said back then six months ago there's a
couple of distinctions you could draw I
mean one is an important one which is
um you know back in February when he
made that threat
um he announced a specific change to
Russia's nuclear force posture now that
turned out not to be such a big deal it
was to do with the number of personnel
at command posts
um and uh it could have been a lot worse
but there was a specific change
announced to Russia's nuclear posture
that didn't happen on this occasion
um another distinction you could draw is
Putin set out this fairly expansive set
of circumstances in the most recent
threat in which he would use nuclear
weapons
um which were different from the
somewhat different from the
circumstances he made in February
but I think he shouldn't over try and
over interpret that to my mind the
difference between what Putin said then
and what Putin said now or what Putin
said now and Russia's uh official
nuclear declaratory posture
um I worry that those differences are
more about a more noise than they are
Sigma that is to say that a lot of
people try to read these threats like
lawyers uh assuming that any slight
differences between what said now and
what said previously uh are the result
of careful deliberation and a very
deliberate signaling on Putin's part
indicating changes in the circumstance
in which he may use nuclear weapons
my I am skeptical that that much thought
went into this I see these much more as
kind of
um reflexive moves by an angry and
cornered leader now that doesn't make
them any less dangerous I think this is
a dangerous situation and I take these
threats seriously but my point rather is
that analyzing precise differences in
wording between then and now as I say I
think that signal rather the noise
sorry sorry I think that's noise rather
than signal well just to kind of get to
that sort of big picture point you know
that what you just said there that a
sense of of a leader being cornered and
many people have said this that that
this seems you know an act of
desperation rather than strength by
Putin now we spoke uh after those
um those initial threats at the
beginning of the war and we'll put a
link to that in the notes to this video
um but during that conversation I
rewatched it you said that the scenario
that concerned you most was a scenario
maybe a little bit like what we're
seeing now that Putin feels cornered and
his rule begins to look under threat and
I think many have interpreted that with
this step now he's kind of digging
further into a hole in terms of this war
so given that context do you feel it is
beginning to look more like this
scenario that concerned you most and are
you say more worried and concerned than
you were six months ago so the first
thing to say is I think you use is not
imminent
I would have been much more concerned if
Putin had issued an order like removing
nuclear warheads for non-strategic
Delivery Systems from Storage uh and
preparing to meet those Warheads with
their Delivery Systems that's not
something we saw I also think that if
nuclear use had been imminent then or
you know if Putin was seriously
considering nuclear use in the short
term we would have seen very specific
demands from Putin so you know in a
general sense
um I don't think nuclear use is imminent
I am somewhat less concerned than I was
back in February
um
I was you know when Putin issued his
order to increase the alert level of
Russian nuclear forces before we
understood what that order actually
meant that was a very concerning moment
and I'm not as concerned then but I am
concerned
um the way that I view it is there are
three circumstances
that I think would make nuclear use by
Russia more likely
the first would be a catastrophic
military defeat the second would be
Putin losing his hold on Power and the
third would be
um uh the Russian economy on the brink
of complete collapse and I've been
saying for a few months now that those
conditions could emerge but they didn't
look at all proximal to me and I think
you know there are from Russia's
perspective here there are some worrying
trend lines
um you know Ukraine is available a long
way from winning this war
um but there is the possibility that
Ukraine will take back Ukrainian
territory that Russia illegally and
wrongly but considers Russian territory
um you know
um uh including probably most
importantly Crimea from Russia's
perspective okay we're seeing some
protests in Moscow
um my at the beginning of the war we saw
protests they emerged they they they
they were dissipated very uh rapidly uh
I'm not expecting right now to see uh
serious threats to Putin's leadership
but I can't absolutely discount that
possibility so you know if as I said you
have these trend lines that from
Russia's perspective look kind of or
from Putin's perspective more
specifically look kind of worrying
um and if you extrapolate these outwards
on a on uh uh
in a way that looks particularly
worrying for Putin then I think nuclear
use could become more likely I want to
talk a little bit about what kind of of
nuclear weapons use it could come to if
it did come to that
um because people talk a little a lot
about the possibilities of potentially a
sort of a warning strike which might
take place sort of perhaps you know even
out over the ocean something like that a
use of a small nuclear weapon in the
battlefield as up against you know the
biggest thing a long-range sort of
strategic strike could you just walk
through a little bit about what do you
think of conceivable scenarios for each
of those or if there are any others I
haven't mentioned and
um what do you think the purpose of each
of those might be the first thing I
think we have to say is we should be
very modest in predicting what Russian
nuclear use would look like we don't
know and honestly I doubt the Russian
military nurse like at the end of the
day it will be up to Putin you know he
may be presented with options but he
will do whatever he thinks is is is best
but it's very very hard to predict what
that could look back I think a
a plausible situation you know plausible
pattern for first use might be something
like a nuclear detonation over the
northern Black Sea
um something like that uh a warning shot
you know maybe over a less inhabited
area of Ukraine I wouldn't entirely rule
out Battlefield use against Ukrainian
formations
in all of those cases though the purpose
would be the same it would basically be
to try to terrify uh Ukraine and I think
particularly Ukraine's Western backers
inter-backing down because of the threat
of further escalation
um
the purpose I think wouldn't the primary
purpose would not be to degrade
Ukrainian forces on the battlefield
clearly nuclear use may have that effect
and that may be an added bonus for Putin
but I don't think that would be the
primary driver for nuclear use I think
it would be aiming to inflict Terror now
if we take one of those scenarios I mean
for instance the sort of the lowest
level of those scenarios you know to
what you described there a destination
of a nuclear weapon may be a relatively
small one in a deserted area over the
Black Sea
um what would then be the you know if we
look at the West that is really trying
to you know warn uh Russia off from
taking any such action what what are the
available options for Action there what
would they be thinking of what is the
appropriate response to a nuclear
detonation that maybe Kills Nobody
just like I don't think we know
what Russian first use would look like I
don't think we know what the Western
response would be one could imagine a
whole range of responses
um
anything from
um conducting a similar demonstration
shot
um through to a demonstration nuclear
shot kinetic but non-nuclear strikes
cyber attacks I mean there's a whole
range of possibilities here
and let me emphasize two things
firstly you know this would be an
enormously dangerous situation
I think that it would part of the
western response would depend on what
the international response was
if
the entire Global Community including
China
said to Russia you have crossed a line
and this is completely unacceptable we
are going to treat you like a pariah
economically politically culturally
and you know even Russia's close friends
like except Iran and China
um treated them in that way
there would be much less of a need for a
military let alone a nuclear response if
the International Community as a whole
fails to act in a robust way against
this kind of Russian outrage then there
would be more pressure on the United
States in particular
um to take prevailing actions including
nuclear use
um second thing to emphasize is you know
I should have said before there are
actually steps Russia could take even
lower down the nuclear ladder than a
demonstration shot I mean you know the
very lowest step that Russia could take
which would still be enormously
provocative to be sure would be an
underground nuclear test on Russian
territory
um that I think would actually be a
pretty hard thing to respond to because
the US isn't going to want to do an
underground nuclear testing in response
um um and you know being on Russian
territory rather than Ukrainian
territory would also make it harder for
us to respond
um and you talk about the the response
by the International Community the the
non-western International Community as
being so important
um just put this in context for us
because there has been a taboo on
nuclear use which goes back all the way
uh to to the only time in which um
nuclear weapons have been used in Anger
um can you just put this in consulate
how much of a of a of a shock to the
International System would even the
lowest level thing well the one of the
lowest level actions here B
um this breach of their taboo how
important would that be yeah so I in
this category I would put Russian
nuclear use on Russian territory in a
different category for Russian nuclear
use anywhere else you know countries
have conducted many nuclear tests on
their own and actually other people's
territory as well but you know anything
like a demonstration shot over the
northern Black Sea really would be kind
of absolutely unprecedented
I think in many ways it would be
arguably the most shocking event to have
happened since the end of the second
World War
um
partly because nuclear weapons haven't
been used in Warfare
um since the bombing of Nagasaki and so
it would break this long tradition of
non-use
but even more so because there would be
some risk of absolutely catastrophic
escalation
um you know civilization ending
escalation
how the numbers I don't know how likely
it would be
um you know hopefully cooler heads would
Prevail long before
um you reached that point but
once the nuclear threshold has been
crossed
there is no guarantee you're going to be
able to stop short at the end of
civilization and I think it would be a
profoundly shocking experience
um and one that
um I don't think we know what the other
side of that event horizon actually
looks like
so this is the the threat that we're
looking at now
um it's you know the second time in six
months that that Putin is being making
this kind of threat
um we've already seen the West try to
respond to this essentially Western
Powers seem to be treating this as a
bluff even though Putin said in his very
comments that it's not a bluff
um what do you think is well what's your
advice to Western leaders thinking about
how to deal with this threat look I
don't think Western leaders are treating
this as a bluff
they're not conceding they're not caving
into
Putin you know they're going to continue
supplying Ukraine with resources and
military equipment
um but I I don't I I've never heard
anybody saying you know I don't think
Western leaders to my knowledge have
said Putin is bluffing you know I think
I think I think I think I think they are
deciding that the risks of uh you know
the cost benefit analysis of supplying
this assistance to Russia is still
positive from a western perspective so I
think it's important to continue to show
a unified face
um I think it's important not to you
know I think everything
the West has done for Ukraine so far has
been reasonable and proportionate and
it's not anything that I oppose
um and I think you know we should stay
the course
at the same time you know there's some
calls
to escalate largely for the sake of
escalating out of this belief that if we
just put enough pressure on Russia uh by
escalating further that
um
um um you know Russia will eventually
climb down
um
I think that that is a mistake to
escalate for the sake of escalating
there may be arguments in time for
supplying longer-range weapons to
Ukraine
um or you know I think we have to judge
those on a case-by-case basis but but
but you know as Biden in particular has
been we should be very wary about
further escalating
and finally I do think that if Putin at
some point in the future decides he
wants a way out if he does not appear to
want at the moment you know we should be
thinking about what that looks like
um and that's going to be a difficult
and painful thing to to think through
but ultimately if our ultimate goal is
to
defend the territorial integrity and
existence of Ukraine as a state I think
the best way of doing that will
ultimately to be to reach some kind of
negotiated settlement now look Putin
doesn't want to talk right now his
demands are completely unreasonable to
the extent he's actually making any
demands at all there's no Prospect of
negotiations in the immediate future but
you know I think we should be you know
and and maybe this war ends without
negotiations but you know I think I
think I think we ought to prepare for
that as a possibility at some point down
the line and to because last time we did
talk about off-ramps six months ago the
importance of providing an off-ramp
the way it looks instead of seeking an
off-ramp Putin is sort of doubling down
further uh you know as as you look at
the sort of trajectory of this does it
look to you like a leader who is sort of
thinking all right I I go down if this
fails I go down
I don't I I not exactly I mean I don't
think Boudin imagines going down I mean
I think his plan is to stay at office
and to stay alive and he can do whatever
is required to do that which is actually
inhibiting Factor on nuclear use it
doesn't preclude the possibility but I
think it it it you know is desire to
stay alive probably does inhibit nuclear
use
um
you know I I I've always thought it's
important to try to provide him with off
ramps
um but he has to undertake those which
he doesn't at the moment I mean you know
he he's clearly doubling down right now
um and and you know so when I talk about
preparing and thinking about what
off-ramps could look like none of that
is done with any expectation that Putin
is going to show any interest in
negotiating in the short term
um finally I'd just like to we talked
interestingly last time about historical
comparisons
um are there any kind of moments in
history that that that you look to
um to see you know any lessons for for
what we're dealing with at the moment
you've got to always got to be careful
here because you know every crisis is
different and those differences can
sometimes be very important
um but going back to this conversation
about offer apps you know if you look at
the most dangerous moment of the nuclear
age keep a missile crisis Kennedy was
prepared and indeed give did give
Khrushchev off ramps in that situation
that involved a
secret promise to withdraw Jupiter
missiles from Turkey uh about six months
after uh the Soviet Union withdrew its
missiles from Cuba
um and that is the kind of creative
thinking that I think is you know
governments ought to be doing behind the
scenes
giving Putin any kind of concessions is
deeply unpleasant and distasteful
um
but just as it was better to give cruise
ship concessions in 62 rather than
increase further the risk of a nuclear
war
um you know I think there's we should be
thinking about what off-ramps in this
current situation look like you know not
least because the Ukrainian people are
going to be suffering
enormously the longer this war continues
for and again like I'm not naive about
any of this you should be very clear
Putin is not seeking an off-ramp at the
moment I'm not confident you know I'm
not just not confident like there's not
going to be serious negotiations I think
in the short term
um but that doesn't I think obviate the
value of starting to think through some
way of helping Putin extricate himself
Through This Disaster uh if he wants it
all right James action thank you very
much for talking to us today and uh yeah
we'll look forward to checking back in
with you
further down the line thank you very
much